bien vamos a hablar acerca de la unidad
de disco compacto o dvd en sí que es
este de aquí móvil la placa de control a
un lado desde su ubicación normal sólo
para que podamos observar los cables
alrededor de ella y además había
retirado los tornillos que sostienen el
dispositivo sólo para ahorrar todo el
tiempo que toma quitarlos y así poder
explicarlo aquí pueden ver que la
energía para los motores viene de estos
dos cables que tenemos aquí
este chip controla los pulsos eléctricos
a través de estos cables y les dice a
los motores que saquen la bandeja que
hagan girar el eje del motor de giro y
que muevan el láser de atrás hacia
adelante así que hay tres funciones ahí
y por lo tanto vamos a requerir tres
motores por lo tanto deberíamos de ver
tres motores en la parte superior así
que primero vamos a retirar estos cables
de aquí y bueno en este cable de aquí es
un cable plano observa este es el que
toma las señales del láser y las regresa
hasta la placa recuerda que las señales
son
los eléctricos que son codificados en
unos y ceros y después esta placa
convierte esos unos y ceros en una señal
analógica que permite a la televisión
leerla y bueno posiblemente tenga
señales digitales pero creo que
solamente tiene salidas analógicas vamos
a quitar este cable plano este de aquí
si podemos perfecto ya está hay un
montón de cosas interesantes que debemos
saber acerca de este cable plano una de
ellas por ejemplo es que tiene un montón
de cables muy finos que permiten que las
señales sean enviadas y que tiene esta
pieza rígida de plástico hasta el final
la cual permite que sea más fácil
conectarla a esta ranura tan estrecha
muy bien ahora vamos a observar la
unidad del dvd y lo primero que quiero
que analicemos es la estructura y los
componentes mecánicos y en el siguiente
vídeo vamos a observar el láser y cómo
funciona en esta parte vamos a girar lo
tenemos varios componentes diferentes
primero observa que tenemos tres motores
justo como esperábamos y recuerda el
primer motor este que tenemos aquí hace
girar el eje porque es el motor de giro
y después tenemos este otro motor que en
realidad lo que hace es guiar el
engranaje que hace que se mueva el láser
por aquí puedes ver cómo se desplaza de
atrás hacia adelante y este motor hace
que la bandeja se deslice hacia fuera
del reproductor y así puedas colocar tu
disco para que gire dentro y sea leído y
bueno entre todo esto hay numerosas
cosas de ingeniería que realmente son
fascinantes en todo ello por ejemplo una
de las cosas que tienen que hacer con
una placa como ésta es que todo
permanezca en su lugar esto es muy
importante para que todo sea preciso y
es que debe de haber un grado de
precisión muy alto porque el disco es
leído en un lugar muy pequeño y el
hacerle una parte muy pequeña de este
disco y para poder lograr esto toda la
placa debe estar bien alineada y para
lograrlo hay diversos elementos
mecánicos y electromecánicos que
posible una de las cosas que hace esto
posible son los dos interruptores de
control del lazo cerrado estos
interruptores lo que hacen es que este
dispositivo se mueva hacia adelante y
hacia atrás y que también pare todo en
función del tiempo así que el
temporizador de aquí en la computadora
dice bien cinco segundos en esta
dirección y cuando llegue al final ahora
cinco segundos en la otra dirección y
etcétera etcétera
esto está genial excepto por el hecho de
que los engranes están un poco afloja
dos y con el tiempo andando hacia
adelante y hacia atrás
el láser puede desalinearse o salirse de
su posición donde debe de estar así que
los ingenieros han llegado a una
solución muy ingeniosa y exponer un
interruptor de control de lazo cerrado
lo que significa que hay un interruptor
que es accionado cada vez que láser
llega al final cuando este mecanismo de
cremallera de aquí que también se le
conoce como cremallera el piñón es decir
me refiero está en grande redondo y los
dientes en el borde recto lo que hace
este mecanismo extra
el movimiento rotacional en movimiento
lineal y después de esto desde pequeño
en grande al en grande grande se
lentifica el movimiento del motor y es
así como se entiende un movimiento suave
además incrementa la fuerza de torsión o
la energía del motor así que tener estas
proporciones clave permite que el
movimiento sea más suave y lento y con
un poco más de energía controlada así
que cuando esto llega al final del ciclo
acciona el interruptor lo presiona hacia
abajo y reinicia el dispositivo entero
es justo así como sabe que hey esto está
en cero y se reinicia otra vez por lo
tanto no tienes que preocuparte si se
desalinea hay otro interruptor de
control del lazo cerrado justo aquí y
esto es porque es muy muy importante que
todo permanezca verdaderamente alineado
y para eso tenemos los dos interruptores
aquí estos hace que se reinicie cada vez
que la bandeja del cde se abre y se
cierra así que cada vez que se abre y se
cierra se reinician y permite al
controlador del motor
y la placa de control saber que estoy en
cero de nuevo y así sabe cómo ejecutar
la secuencia de nuevo exactamente de la
manera que debe ser si se usa un
temporizador u otra forma para controlar
el motor podría empujar el dispositivo
muy lejos o empujarlo contra otro
plástico o dónde sale el motor pero
cuando obtienes este interruptor lo
puede reiniciar cada vez y así mantener
las cosas funcionando sin problemas
además vamos a observar este soporte
metálico de aquí que está sujetando
estos dos motores este motor de giro y
este otro que es el motor que mueve a
láser y están montados en este soporte
metálico lo que significa que están muy
estables y sólidos lo que hace rígido
este soporte son estos dobleces que lo
hacen realmente fuerte y resistente
porque le agregan rigidez al metal y
aquí hay dos piezas de hule y estos
tornillos y estas piezas de eeuu le
permiten que la placa del dispositivo
pueda agacharse me refiero a esta placa
metálica cuando el debe de sal en la
placa pivota hacia abajo de ésta
ahora si lo volteamos puedes ver que
aquí tenemos el cambio está el giratorio
o el eje que está sobre la bandeja y si
él te puede entrar así de golpe entonces
pegaría justo ahí y no funcionaría así
que la bandeja debe irse hacia abajo
ahora bien estos tornillos que están a
los lados permiten que la bandeja se
mueva hacia abajo y fuera del camino así
cuando el cabezal deja de girar esto se
despliega hacia abajo y el dvd puede
retirarse y de manera contraria cuando
el dvd se coloca adentro encaja justo
aquí y este soporte se eleva
agarra el dvd y permite que gire
libremente de manera que así no se hace
fricción con el plástico y así es como
funciona esta parte pero bueno lo que
quiero recordarles es que el metal es
importante ya que le da rigidez a la
plataforma y ayuda a mantener esa
estabilidad dimensional la cual es
necesaria para mantener todo en su sitio
y también por aquí puedes ver las dos
barras metálicas que están estrechamente
conectadas en el soporte de metal
ellas permiten que el láser realice
suavemente su movimiento a través de
este borde y pueden ver que hay un punto
de contacto aquí y luego hay un borde
largo que permite mantener la precisión
constante y el movimiento suave estas
barras son lisas y pulidas y permiten
que el láser se mueva con suavidad
pueden ver que estas son piezas de
plástico moldeadas por inyección estas
barras de aquí definitivamente le dan
rigidez y fuerza y bueno completan la
unidad del dvd además de mantener todos
los diferentes componentes juntos